hello there today we're going to look at
not all memories are created equal
learning to forget by expiring and the
system
also known as expire span it's by
sanbaya subbata da ju spencer poff
stephan roller arthur slum jason weston
and angela fun of facebook ai research
and lauria in this paper on a high level
the authors propose a modification
to the transformer attention mechanism
that allows these systems potentially to
include
much longer context spans
the way they do it is that they don't
want to attend
to all of the context but in an
auto regressive way in each time step
they want to
decide is this particular time step
worth remembering or not and if so then
for how long so after a while these
memories of the past
expire and then they are dropped and the
system can learn itself
which things are important to remember
for the future
and which ones aren't so it has some
good things it has some limitations it's
very strong
in in tasks where you explicitly have to
remember
individual things for a long period of
time
so we'll dive into the system right here
it's a pretty simple
idea i think and uh it
appears to work on the tasks that they
produce
so yeah as always if you
like this don't hesitate to share this
out and
tell all your friends about it i'm sure
they are
very very interested so they say
uh the attention mechanisms have shown
promising
results in sequence modeling tasks that
require long
term memory right so the
they say however not all content in the
past is equally important to remember
we propose expire span a method that
learns to retain
the most important information and
expire
the irrelevant information they say
these forgetting
of memories enables transformers to
scale to attend over tens of
thousands of previous time steps
efficiently as not all states from the
previous
time steps are preserved
so again this is the core idea right
here
if you have a sequence model like a
transformer
and in this case particular we consider
a sort of auto regressive
decoder only sequence model which means
that
for the next token to predict like this
one right here
we only care about the the past and not
the future so this is a
unidirectional sort of auto-regressive
style
decoder so every token can attend
to its past now
if you want to predict the fourth token
right here in an attention mechanism
you have to pay attention so to say
to three things in the past right
if you want to predict the next token
the fifth token right here you have to
attend
to this previous one but also all the
other previous ones so to four
in the past if you want to predict you
see what's coming right
if you the more the longer your sequence
gets the more
things you need to attend to in the past
which gives us this traditional o of
n squared uh computation and memory
requirements that
attention mechanisms have so if you get
to
very very long sequences this can
become a problem because uh you always
need to attend to everything
in the past so imagine this is whatever
a sentence
the cat sat on
the mat now
not not all words they say right here
are equally important so
for example it would be easy if you
wanted to predict this word right here
matt it will be pretty easy to do so
even if you don't remember that the word
the
is in front of here right the word
the word sat here sat on
seems pretty important because you know
to sit
on something is a good indication that
there is maybe a mat
there or a chair or something like this
right so these seem to be worth
remembering while the word
the is maybe not as important the word
cat
might be semi-important
and we would like a system that learns
to sort of
forget and remember the correct
words right here if we only remember the
more
important pieces of information and we
discard
here in this case this word the
then we we also have one
less thing to attend to and
the goal is if we can get the number of
important things down then it won't be
n squared but it will be something like
o of
n times m where m
is the size of the memory that
we have this work here doesn't have an
explicitly
sized memory rather it does the
following
it goes over every element in the
sequence
and every element in the sequence of
course gives you sort of
goes through a bunch of layers gives you
a prediction
right so here is a prediction uh i
misplaced this let's go down a bit
further here
so every element in the sequence gives
you first of all a hidden state
right h here this and it gives you a
prediction like
y okay so this is h one and y one
then you go to the next element and that
with consideration right attending
this layer attends to the last layer
gives you
h2 and from that it predicts y2
and so on um
let's do one more so in this layer so in
each layer
the sort of so in each layer
the future attends to the past
and that gives you a prediction
and the attention is over these
h right here over this hidden state now
what this model does is it adds one
component
in each time step it doesn't only
predict the
the output of this particular time step
if there even is an output
right it also predicts
this number they call e and e
is the expiration duration
of that particular memory so
e is produced every time
from h and e tells you
how long you should remember that
particular h
so here for example h3
also attends to h1 i forgot to draw this
in right here right
now let's say that e1 here
is two okay saying that this
particular memory should be valid for
two time steps i'm not going to need it
longer than two time steps
now let's say the the fourth
so the next sequence tokens comes in h4
and h4 is produced of course by
attending to the past
but now you want to attend to h3
to h2 and because you want to attend to
all of the past
you want to attend to h1 but because
this h1 is already expired you can't
so the the the system would it would
drop h1 you no longer can attend to
h1 so this is different
from just a fixed window right if you
have a sequence
what people previously did was something
like local attention
where you say okay i have a window of
like
size l which is four and if i predict
this this token right here i can attend
to the past four things if i then
predict this one i can attend to the
past four things if i predict this one
i can attend to these past four things
so this here is different in the sense
that
if you have a fixed window again
everything is the same
importance but you just limit how far
you can look back this
works to an extent but if there is
something really important
right here you will forget it no matter
what
however in expire span this thing right
here can say well i have an
expiration date of 1
million billion right 1 million billion
so for 1 million billion future time
steps things will be able to
attend to that important piece of
information
however if you can say for the next
thing
well i only i expire immediately
this is not worth remembering for the
future okay
so i hope you got the principle right
here they also have a drawing
here where you can see these hidden
states are produced
and these hidden states are produced
naturally from forward propagating
through the model and for each of these
hidden states
one expiration date is produced
and now in the future when i want to
produce the next
hidden state or you know the next output
of the next layer i can look
at the past and i only consider the
things
where the expiration date hasn't passed
yet
so for anything else like this one right
here or this one right here their
expiration date
was just too short so this is uh
and only only these go into the
attention mechanism
so this is a dynamic way of saying
how long a memory should last now you
can immediately
sort of see the weaknesses of this right
here
you have to know at the beginning like
at the moment where you produce the
signal
you have to know for how long it's going
to be valid and that's certainly
that is certainly you know the case for
some things that you have to remember
like when you come across
a name in a story that
is maybe something that you know okay
i'm going to remember
that piece of information very well
because
probably it's going to be important um
but not
for all right so sometimes something big
something that you thought wasn't
important maybe this thing right here
you you just you read it it's in a
sequence of text you read that word
and you know it doesn't seem too
important but then
all of a sudden because this word um
is something so you read on all of a
sudden
that password becomes super duper
important and you shouldn't forget it
and this is a these are effects that
the system cannot handle the system can
only decide
at the moment where you consume the
token how important is it
how for how long should i remember it
independent
of what happens in the future
you might already know a system that
learns to remember
things over long pieces of time which is
the long short-term memory
uh cell or generally recurrent neural
networks
that have an internal state and then at
each point they decide
how to update that state so this here
is sort of an in between between a
transformer
which you you cannot decide at all how
important
things are and what you should remember
it's either you remember
all of it or part of it and the lstm on
the other hand that
dynamically updates its internal memory
every single time step right so it can
make remembering something dependent
even on the future
um this yeah as i said this this is done
for computational reasons mostly
because lstms you have to you have to
train one after the other you have to
back prop through time
here you can still get away with a bit
of parallelism i
i think at least though i would argue
if i could extend this i would argue
that if you consider the point
where something expires i would
maybe build in something where the
system can decide
to re-retake
this into memory or you know like
such that the system can revise its own
predictions about
how important each of the memories are
and if you look at this in
in a let's say a computational point
they base their work off transformer xl
so transformer xl
is sort of the baseline right here what
transformer xl does is
it has long sequences and then it
considers
blocks of those sequences and they do
the same here
so you just you chunk these sequences
into
different blocks okay now for each of
the elements here you output a vector
which is this this hidden
state now what transformer xl does
is it does the attention in
block one just as it would do
regularly and then in block two and then
in block
three so it chunks the sequence and
handles the blocks individually however
in block
two in order to you know
look back because we always want to look
back we want to remember things
what you do is you put the hidden states
that you produced in block one you sort
of put them
into like a little bit of a of a
register i would say so you put them
into so these are the vectors i just lay
them on their side
right these are the vectors and you put
them just there
um there is a sort of a stop gradient
right here but you just you just kind of
put them to make them available
for the next block so what the next
block can do when you want to
predict for example the hidden state of
this thing it can attend
to obviously to the sequence elements
in its own block right because you
consider the block as a whole
but it can also attend to these things
right here and again you produce
that hidden state ultimately from it and
from it every element in that block and
those go
then to be available for the next block
to attend to
and you can even remember multiple
blocks like this so you can sort of
carry forward this block as well
right and now block three can attend to
the last two
blocks however um you can't do this
infinitely right
otherwise you're going to run into the
same problems but at least
this handles a bit of the the back prop
issues and also these things right here
they cannot attend
to each other right there is no need for
them to attend to each other
so you don't have n squared you have
n times whatever that here um
so if this is m and this here
is n you have o of n
times n plus m no
sorry um yeah but n is way smaller so
it's n squared but n is way small
n isn't the whole sequence length i'm
maybe b
let's call this b the block size right
and
this here at maximum is
n so you have a way smaller sort of
um way smaller could radic blow up only
inside the block
and you can even compress these memories
here of transformer xl you can max pool
you can learn to compress them
and so on so this is the system
that they base off of right
they also consider sequences in these
blocks
where inside the block it's just regular
attention
and then you can attend to the past as
you would in transformer excel
except that um some of these past
memories
they are forgotten so here these are
maybe
forgotten and maybe this one is
forgotten too
until you are here right and then during
that time
you know one more expired so you can see
there is a lot less
stuff around so you get away with having
a smaller memory
and you can potentially up the time
that you can look back into the past if
you only have a limited set of slots
available here
you know you can increase that so that's
i hope that is a bit clear how they do
it they go
block by block and in each block
they look back um and they build this
this memory uh right here so this
this memory here that
inside the next block they can also
attend to
but in the memory other than transformer
xl they
only consider things that have not
expired yet
and the expiration is determined
at the moment where the signal where the
hidden state
is produced in fact
the expiration here is pretty simple so
you take that hidden state that's
produced
by the network and you simply perform a
logistic regression on top of it so the
logistic regression here will give you
something in the
range 0 to 1 and you multiply that by l
and
l is the maximum possible
length of remembering
right now these are all
you know design choices you know that
the the sigmoid function here used in
logistic regression is a rather
let's say rather steep function so there
is a region
where you sort of go
up quite quickly but there are also
large regions where it's just
uh all or nothing right
so i get i'm going to guess that this
function here
will be either remember this or
don't remember this maybe there will be
some in the middle
but which tells me that this l
setting right here might be fairly
important
that you tune that for the task that you
want to consider
another thing they say is
okay how do we actually implement this
and they implement this
via a mask okay like
if you have a bunch of things that you
could attend
to right the way that you don't attend
to everything
is by masking out uh attention
attention parameters essentially or
elements of that
map so if i draw the same sequence twice
the attention matrix is of course
constructed by
outer product of keys and queries
right so here is the attention matrix
every cell gets a value
of how much uh this
x here attends to this y
and as you know that
already in these decoder things we need
a mask
because this thing here cannot attend to
this thing here
this thing here would be like this thing
here so it cannot attend so
all the upper triangular
thing right here is already dark
well okay i can't draw but
we usually implement this with a mask
right because
gpus aren't super good at doing
triagonal
matrices so we just put a mask here and
we say everything up here
is off limits okay now if
we also say well this
let's say this thing here has an
expiration date of two
which means that this can still attend
to it
this can still attend to it but this
here cannot attend to it
so what we need to do is
well i might have drawn this slightly
weird but let's say
that is this
no it's not correct but you go to that
cell
and you also mask that out
you say you cannot attend to anything
that's expired
so what you end up with is sort of this
mask where
you fill in um
yeah i think after that it should all be
black right
where at some point uh the the row
will just be masked out uh from then
on so the light squares here have a
value of
1 and the dark squares value of 0
meaning that you don't consider these
things in the attention
anymore that's how it's implemented
if you just do that
then you have a problem on your hand
okay
because this is not differentiable
simply putting
them asking whether or not
this r number r is
is the thing still valid you see it's
constructed from e
which is the expiration uh duration and
the t which is the current time step
and i which is um the
i from the e so you look back and say is
this thing still valid
and this number if it's positive it's
still valid if it's negative
it's no longer valid if this becomes
negative
it indicates the memory is expired and
can be removed
from the set you attend to so you
construct a mask
with just everything all the r's that
are positive
and use that mask in the attention like
you already do
with the masking out future tokens
this is not differentiable okay
however they say with such discrete
masking the x bar span will not receive
any gradient for training instead we use
a soft masking function
that smoothly transitions from zero to
one
and this is what you can see right here
so essentially how this works is
here is a memory produces a hidden state
and it says i am valid for three steps
three steps so
that means that the mask here how does
the mask look
the mask for this particular thing
looks as follows so here is zero
and here is one um the mask
okay well yeah the mask starts at one
for one two
three and then it drops off
linearly until it's at
zero you can see this right here so
here's the min
of one which means that um
it can never be higher than one the max
of zero which means that it cannot be
lower than zero
and then in between it's governed by
this
rule right here which you can see r is a
hyper parameter
saying that like a ramp drop off
um yeah the length of a ramp that is
bound between zero and one
and the higher this r is if it's
negative
then we're in this decreasing regime
okay so this is the mask now you can
also immediately see
that talking about gradients right the
only place
where the module that generates
e right this is a we
we generate this here the hidden state
goes into a neural network
neural network and that generates this
expiration date
the only place where that neural network
gets a learning signal
gets a gradient is during this drop-off
no not before not after the only time
where this network gets any learning
signal at all
is during this thing so
it is quite important these parameters
right this this here
this is upper bounded by the parameter l
and then this thing right here is
modulated
by the parameter r
so these hyper parameters i feel have
are
quite important to how this
task is going to play out if you
actually want to learn anything
because let's say in a sequence
here is something that you need to
remember but you need to remember
it for here
if the l is too
short right you will maximally remember
it
till here and then it's gone even if the
l is large enough right
then you won't get any training signal
for this
unless sort of the let's say the l
the l is large enough so this is your
expiring span
and then it it sort of drops off the
importance drops off
and only if that drop-off happens to
coincide
with you know the thing where it's
important you do get a learning signal
that
hey maybe you should remember that thing
for longer next time because i'm gonna
need it
right if that is not the case if
your expiration prediction is like this
and your drop-off is done here
then you will never get a learning
signal that
hey there might be something here where
you should remember this thing
this is the i mean it's the same problem
you get anywhere where you're dealing
with
long sequences and
it is it is a problem because ultimately
if you want to have a general training
method where
anywhere in the future there could be
something important you
have to you you're going to have sort of
this quadratic
um this quadratic thing where
you technically have to attend to all
the things in the past
even a little bit because you want to
make it differentiable because you want
to learn
to remember right if you always forget
and then there is something here you
don't know anymore that there was
something to remember
you'd somehow need a learning signal i
guess
you could break this maybe you could
break this down
into maybe not n squared but maybe like
n log
n where you sort of build up a tree of
the past
and then you
somehow realize that okay
there is something to remember you don't
maybe don't know what but maybe there is
something to remember
this might have been done already in any
case i just wanted to show you that
the learning signal here is very
small like the window where you can
learn something is very small
and that means the kind of tasks it can
be applied to
or maybe not as much as many
as you would hope
what they also do is they put an l1
penalty
so an l1 penalty onto these expiration
things so they encourage the network
to rather forget things this is in order
to keep
the um to keep the
just the predictions small you don't
want the network you don't want the
network by default to say
well none of this is important and only
if you get a learning signal that
something is important
then the network should predict high
numbers
so ultimately you're going to have a
a sequence right i'm going to draw it
like this this time
and the network will predict various
spans
to expire these memories and the first
thing you do
is you'll say okay everyone just kind of
you know kind of go down go down go down
go down and then if
let's say this thing right here
really profits from this thing right
here
in the sequence then and if
if uh this has been going down
enough such that the
later one is in this ramp portion this
this this r portion of the former one
then you get a learning signal saying
hey maybe you should remember that thing
for
longer right and then hopefully
hopefully
some next thing right here will also
benefit
from remembering this thing and now that
is in this
span sorry in this ramp region which
will give
here another boost to remember it for
longer
so this is how you learn you sort of
need a continuous
reinforcing signal over different
time steps in order to learn you
the this long range thing it's it's
i don't think that generally is
learnable with this system you need
these
intermediate things or you need some
kind of randomness to discover it
and this is very close right to um
reinforcement learning now
all right and yeah so
it's what they do here they also they
have some practical considerations
where they say okay because we we cache
these things
like the question is how do you back
prop how do you even back propagate
through something like this i said there
was a stop gradient
uh right here what you do is you cache
the h you cache these things and then as
far as i understand
you do compute the
attention like the expiration things on
the fly
like you cache the hidden states
and then you compute the should you mask
them or not you compute
that thing on the fly and so you can
back propagate
yeah you can back propagate to these
variables
even in the future because you have the
h's cache
i don't think the back prop flows back
to when the hidden states were produced
because
well it can't right because you you
cache it
you don't have the graph available
anymore so they have a bunch of
practical considerations right here
and now they test this so they test this
in various tasks
for example there are these
reinforcement learning tasks there are
these
text instruction tasks there is
character level
language modeling collision detection
where you have a video you go frame by
frame
so these tasks i guess except the
language modeling tasks
are quite constructed such that you have
to remember long things
particularly interesting for example is
this one
right here where they do have this
character level language model and then
they look at
what does it learn to remember and you
can see right here
if the sentence is powerful influence in
egypt right
and they say this the model strongly
memorizes the two areas
egypt and alexander so if you look
egypt right here and this is the
visualization of the expiration
time this is strongly remembered
if you replace in the same model you
just replace this with the word
somewhere all of a sudden the model
doesn't
remember it anymore and if you replace
it with
humpty dumpty again the model remembers
it
quite uh well so
this is an indication that the model has
in fact learned
that you know if there is something uh
special
and they claim if it's a name um
if it's a name or something like this
the model remembers it
well they also say the the rare words
remembers those in memory and i'm asking
myself is this just a function of let's
say complexity
sorry perplexity like could you just
remember the things where the model
perplexity is pretty high instead of
learning what to remember right so you
just
remember sort of the things that you
would not have predicted
i'm going to guess the learned
remembering is better
just because it's learned so it can also
remember
things that have a a low
like that have a big probability but
might still be important
i want to talk just a little bit about
this first
task right here to show you the kind of
tasks where this
could be good at so here you have a grid
world reinforcement learning approach
and you're at the start you were able to
observe
the colors of the fields you're on right
so you're at this start right here and
this is either blue or red and then what
you need to do is you need to
walk all the way through this long
corridor
and then you need to go to the correct
door and the correct door
is whichever one was you know the collar
was at the beginning
and the long corridor is made such that
it is too long to be in the same block
right it's too long to consider in one
attention operation at the same time
and this model they say it learns
to remember the correct thing
with very little effort so here you can
see
the the um the comparison
to transformer xl so transformer xl also
has the ability to remember that right
it can simply
attend to this thing in
in the past if given enough memory
so here you have the memory size and
you can see it starts out by being just
kind of random
because it doesn't remember it like the
memory size is too small to actually
remember
and as you give it more and more memory
it learns
um to attend to the correct thing in
that memory
however expire span it doesn't have a
set memory
right you can with the l1 penalty
you can sort of modulate how long it
forgets things but these here are just
five random
samples i guess of the same model and
you can see that it solves the task
pretty well
while it's effective memory size if you
calculate
like if you look at you know what what
things you do remember
uh stays relatively low so it
learns to remember this correct thing
right here which is pretty cool right
however this there is details of how
this task was constructed i already said
if it's just a long thing then um
then we this is like if this was just a
long corridor this was unlearnable so if
you look at the details
here in the appendix um
where is it yeah the corridor task the
corridor
length is sampled from between 3
and 200 right so
and for the x bar span we set the
maximum span
to 200 so it's it's able to remember
which
again this l seems to be an important
hyper parameter and the ramp length to
16. so
so what does this mean right if
if you have a
let's say a i don't even know how many
things they consider at the moment
like what's their their block length
i'm sure that's stated somewhere
okay but in this corridor task
reinforcement learning
problem right if you
sample things that are just 200 apart
right i guess you you can learn
uh because your l is 200 right but
your predictions you know they if they
are too
short then you never learn
to to get up there and if they're too
long okay you have the nl1 penalty which
makes them shorter and shorter and
shorter and eventually come into the
field of learning
but here you sample at randomly so
sometimes it's
three and sometimes it's 200 and
sometimes it's here and sometimes it's
here
so you give you give the model a
really nice training signal where
however wherever it currently has
learned
for however long it currently has
learned to remember things
there's going to be this ramp and
there's going to be some training runs
where the length of the corridor exactly
falls into this ramp and that will give
it a training signal saying hey
you maybe should remember that thing for
longer okay
for longer then the ramp is here and
then there will be
some kind of problem that exactly falls
into this ramp
right so as in reinforcement learning
you it is best i'm going to argue
if you sort of if your
loss structure guides the model
to remember things for longer
of course this doesn't work in the
character level modeling but
there i i think the text is naturally
structured such that if it's something
important to remember
you will find instances where that comes
after
10 tokens and you will find instances
where the need to remember comes after
20 and 50 and 100
and so on so yeah not for every task but
certainly for many tasks
this might be a good solution again i
would advocate
to add the ability of the model to
refresh
these memories not full lstm style so
not
internally compute and uh update an
internal state or something but just to
go there
and say well in the light of this new
evidence
this thing right here that i want wanted
to forget now
it might still be quite important right
so that would be my first extension and
my second extension would be
instead of building some sort of a
bank right here that you can attend to
maybe you build
some sort of a tree like some some kind
of a merkle tree-ish
thing ins but not with hashes but
with um with hidden
latent variables i'm sure maybe this has
already been done
okay that was my two cents to this paper
i think it's a pretty cool paper
um if you have problems that have super
long
sequences and you have a clear structure
where it's important to remember
key pieces of information a few key
pieces of information
over long distances and if that
is if those distances are somehow
distributed a bit
such that it's not only super long
distances
this might work wonders
so tell me what you think in the
comments and that was it for me bye-bye